welcome back it's time for drew's news
rossi you have a story that you brought
to the table well that's right drew you
know uh my favorite group ever my first
concert was the spice girls thank you
very much
uh
and i have a story about fashion maiden
victoria beckham the wall street journal
reports she is semi-horrified by some of
her old 90s looks but her kids think
they're really cool because the 90s
style is totally coming back and i tell
you the best uh victoria beckham story
though ever uh spilled please so one
time i was covering the olympics in
london and i was flying back and i sat
in the plane and i'm all ready and then
who walks in but posh spice and she sits
behind me so i because i'm me i tweet
omg posh by sitting behind me on a plane
send and then the captain's like we're
gonna sit on the tarmac for a while i'm
like oh no oh no because then she tapped
me on my shoulder and she's like hello i
saw you tweeted about me right
i was like just kidding just kidding and
then the plane took off and she was in
like a sideways black hat and the mini
dress everything stilettos this big she
went into the bathroom and guess what
changed into like full head to toe
cashmere
leggings and uggs and a long sweater it
knows everything it's like i didn't even
think she would own that
uggs drew
uggs right and then she comes back and
she talked to me like the whole flight
she was so nice and i was like is this
the same like victoria beckham and then
guess what right before we landed
back in the bathroom
put on the victoria beckham outfit right
and then when we landed she got out and
the paparazzi was all over her and i
just like i'm like did that happen was i
really next to victoria beckham in uggs
on a plane
and i've never seen her again since
why don't i tweet her and tell her to
come on the show yes right oh my gosh
please come on my old friend
vicky
well we've got some breaking science
news i read this in the new york times
and i was really fascinated with it and
i wanted to share it with you guys um
the bbc reports that surgeons in the u.s
have successfully tested a pig kidney
transplant into a human now the
recipient didn't reject it and it's
functioning normal yeah
so it could have a very big impact
because 90 000 people a year are usually
waiting for a kidney this is just so i
don't even know what to think of it
other than i can't believe that this is
actually happening it seems like
something out of a futuristic novel or
movie well it's the beauty of science
you know and how miraculous that this
person's body didn't reject the part you
know there was a side effect though he
turned into a real ham
[Laughter]
i'm sorry you were just bacon for that
one i had to give it
um and before we go i would love to give
you guys a pic from the little yellow
book which is a list and guide that i
make personally to curate stuff that i
think maybe you would want to know about
no there's no life-altering intestines
in there but um
they always say eat your greens also as
a mom or just someone who can enjoy the
sweet stuff in life i am obsessed with
these okay they're from a company that
my friend don russell makes it's called
eight greens it's really extraordinary
and so they just made these new
lollipops and i thought you know what
when people want a sweet treat this
actually
is made with honest-to-goodness greens
and it's going to surprise you because
you think oh huh okay
i i thought it was going to taste like a
salad
that is delicious and i'm telling you
with every lick you're basically getting
a bite of a salad spinach aloe vera
wheatgrass kale say what uh-huh
sucker
done russell and eight greens you have
done it again i can't wait to give these
to my kids and enjoy them for myself i
hope you enjoy them too
[Music]